sunny sharma welcome to the show
thank you thank you for having me
it's our pleasure and honor and
i'm very grateful that our audiences
recommended this yeah i'm glad you
reached out
i read the comment that you sent yeah
it was great to see that
someone seeing the
bench of awareness analogy
that we posted had also seen the train
station analogy
that you posted and was like pattern
matching
yeah funny how things come about
i love that yeah and
you are very prolific in the space of
creating content around spiritual
understanding
maturity self-realization non-duality
you and also have made good content
around empowerment and manifestation
so these are totally our
core subjects of interest so
beautiful so let's see where our
conversation takes us today
yeah exactly
i'm curious
you carry the simultaneity of
already always
enlightened and free
and perfect while simultaneously
carrying the
there are clearly people that are
trapped in a noisy mind
that are seeking to heal the confusion
and
reunite with the kingdom of god within
do you hold those simultaneously
when you go into interpreting it like
that and i feel
when i myself try to go into
interpreting it like that i just get
confused
and i and i fail to do so so
i i like to put it this way
there's noise and there's the underlying
silence
so being in touch with the
underlying silence which is not
appearing but which is allowing
the noise to appear i would say
that is the the experience and
and that's the experience whether or not
we acknowledge it
so simply the acknowledging knowingly
being that is perhaps what these
teachings direct us towards
okay beautiful it's a great start
so
the noise and the underlying
silence or another way to put it
is the silence
in the symphony allows the notes to
appear
absolutely
and that's why
i believe it's so much about
what interests you you know we're too
interested
in the noise stimulated
by the noise
stimulated by what appears
and that in that so in that immersion is
a sort of blindedness
to the to the screen on which it is
appearing
so one of the things that
sometimes i i ask people to to look at
and invite them to do is let go of being
so
interested in what happens
let go of being so interested in
how this one turns out or how the
experience of this one turns out
because it is in that interest you know
that
that's where the concerns arise that's
where the the fears or the deep
attachments and clinging arises
which creates that blindedness
and that blindedness then we experience
as suffering
and so it to some it may sound crazy
especially when you just encounter
a teaching like this it may sound crazy
to to
to stop caring so much or being so uh
interested in the unfolding of how how
life is going
but that is that is a sort of
willingness
that is required to acknowledge as you
said the the silence
in within the symphony right between the
notes
if you're so immersed and interested in
the the sound silence is not going to be
anything you know it's not even going to
be perceptible same way like the movie
analogy that so many of us are familiar
with if we're
so immersed in the movie
you're not going to acknowledge the
screen a sort of blindedness will happen
right you know so in order to
acknowledge this
the already existing screen which isn't
being created
or brought about by some sort of effort
it requires a certain um
letting go of being interested in the
images that are appearing on the screen
so to really simplify
what the
mystic traditions are saying
mysticism being defined as
uniting with god or with the absolute
the most simple spiritual
understanding is to
simply recognize the silence
the underlying silence
in which the notes appear
and disappear or in the
screen analogy
just take a look at the device that
you're watching this on right now
whether it's your phone whether it's the
computer monitor the tv
whatever device it is notice
that the screen is being modulated
right now and that all you have to do is
lock the screen or power off the monitor
or the tv
and what you see is a blank screen
and sometimes some of the coolest
things that have ever happened to me
period have come from literally sitting
in the corner of my living room
doing absolutely nothing
and just holding the empty
space and
i'm looking at these four monitors
that are all powered off in the corner
of the room
two two on the studio set to here with
the desktop
and i'm just looking at them and just
what's arising is like
pure ineffable beauty
that is always already present yet that
is
rarely ever truly acknowledged and
embodied and i this is a really strong
analogy or another one is the the blank
canvas is another great one so
we actually keep one for this exact
[Music]
purpose
yes
we have them on set
so the blank canvas
right where rarely ever
you go into an art exhibit
the gallery what is the same
across all of the pieces of art
the fact that they're on a blank canvas
or you look at the pages of a book right
what underlies the text all the
differentiations in the text
all the appearances is the blank
paper yeah
now someone may say you know it's okay
it's easy to see that on the level of
okay when you're looking at something
within experience like the blank canvas
or the movie screen when you go to the
cinema
but like how do i bring that to my
direct experience of
of you know my actual experience
and so the the two very very simple ways
um that i usually because i like simple
i don't like anything that complicates
or over complicates this so the pr the
first step to it
is learning to
take a moment to just acknowledge what
is right now what is appearing
what thought what emotion
what sensation
what image
and just acknowledging that not judging
it
not interpreting it not going off into
any story making
not even fighting it not wishing it to
be different
not expecting anything out of it
but first just acknowledging
and once it's been acknowledged
for this moment allowing it to be
you see this immediately dissolves
any sort of contraction any sort of
belief any sort of resistance
to what is appearing right now
whether it be pain or pleasure whether
it be the strongest of sensations or the
mildest of
sensations you simply acknowledging what
is
and you're allowing it to be
and once that step is taken
you can then
see very very clearly that
at the heart of your experience is that
which is aware of it
and so this is perhaps the the thing we
can be sure of most
you know everything else that is
appearing
literally the next moment is very
dreamlike
it literally becomes dust it nowhere to
be found again other than a memory of it
which is also just appearing here and
now
even these words are just floating into
you know nothingness
so the experience what we are aware of
is so unsure so unstable so uncertain
always just changing
but in your conscious experience the
thing that you can be
very sure of is i am aware
and so once you come to a place where
you acknowledge what you are aware of
and not battling and not needing it to
be any different
then you can inquire then you can
investigate
as what am i aware of it you know so
that is that is what
that is the question that is the
curiosity doesn't even have to be a
mental question you know sometimes
the inquiry itself people say just
becomes a mental asking
who am i what am i you know so just this
inward curiosity
as what am i aware of this
it immediately takes your attention away
from
what you are aware of so it immediately
takes your attention away from the
images on the screen and automatically
you are
you are there standing as that which is
aware
and so here not associating
that which is aware with any thought
with any
sensation with an idea of what you
believe is aware
is alive
and just being
that which is aware acknowledging
[Music]
that i am that is that silence
that is the the collapse of objective
focus
simply being as you are and allowing
that which is
to flow to be as it is
and so just in this simple way is
perhaps the entire
teaching you know at least the practice
of it
we often love to go so far deeply into
the non-dual philosophy and videos and
reading and
books and we completely neglect what it
is
simply pointing us to which is this very
collapse of objective focus it's telling
you be quiet
you know so oftentimes i say that that's
like
there are three main components to the
teaching obviously the discussion and
the reading and the
conceptual philosophy is a very vital
part as well
although perhaps the least vital part
second being
silence and then third comes the
integration
right you going through experience
or allowing experience to now
bring to the surface all that is sort of
unconsciously believed in all the
identifications and
and living the implications of
of what you're discovering in the
silence perhaps we can say
so is it concept silence integration
something like that yeah sure cool
discussion
philosophy yeah yeah
reading watching yep
yep
that second
direct experiential
embodiment is
most critical
it's what anchors what we're talking
about
otherwise it just remains
up here so it creates that subtlety
right it makes you it makes your
identity
itself subtler and subtler
it makes your ability to also understand
these abstract concepts perhaps
and confirm and verify them in your
experience otherwise
it's just giving the mind food more
thinking
more fancy ideas which
it hides behind you know
while running away from the silence
so one who just dwells in concepts
becomes very
intellectual in that regard and very
knowledgeable about the teaching
but as you said it's it's just that
surface noise
[Music]
subtle vacation yeah
yeah i was trying to find this word
on the internet and then i realized that
we'll likely be turning
this into a neologism write a new word
the subtlification process
yes yes which has been talked about
across these mystic traditions for
thousands of years but i really like
this sort of
new way
to word it
subtlification is like
moving yourself
further away from objects
and what appears to be like a physical
reality to
recognizing that reality
is completely observer dependent
it's completely consciousness dependent
reality cannot exist without that which
is aware
of the reality so it's a big
shift from the outside
to the inside and so that's already a
massive subtlification because you're
moving from objects to a subject
so a subject itself does not have a form
or a
shape that's why it's called formless
and so that's already a massive subtle
vacation
which is beautiful and then
what we further do like we've been
talking about
is this process of silencing even more
even more silencing
recognizing that this
subject is actually shared the same
observer looking through sunny is
looking through atlas
is looking through the viewers
and then becoming more and more
comfortable with the
shared eternal capital s self
and
becoming aware of the infinitude
of that and the
emptiness of that
and how
we can begin sort of seeing this reality
as
one of endless possibilities
so one of the fun analogies we like to
use is the
food analogy right if this reality is a
beet
salad you know we came from the chicken
soup reality
we're going to the steak and potatoes
reality
you'll never come to the end of all the
possibilities of combinations of food
to taste experience explore to play
[Music]
and perhaps that the emptiness as you
refer to it as what
replenishes you to dance within the
spontaneous and infinite forms
of expression without losing yourself
without once again becoming immersed
and blinded you know life is so sticky
in that regard
your your situations your relationships
your
your work such sticky situations you're
you're always
that are always arising
and and that's the the food for the mind
it loves to you know once again go into
the interpretations the judgments and
then it creates this veil
whereas yes that the silence
is that that ripening factor which
further grounds you
in that non-physical identity
so that you you are able to go uh
be able to go through experience
authentically
we can say not identifying
not not contracting
[Music]
not limiting yourself to a shape
emptiness is
the recharging of the battery
and it's also the detoxifying of
the vehicle itself as well from its
conditioning
from its separate personhood
so it enables
in the most simple
example is that everybody is familiar
with
is what's called the gap or the pause
so when you're in the scenario
typically
most frequently experienced with family
when there's a little bit of a
budding of perspectives is that as soon
as
you take an inhalation
and relax your perspective and needing
to
force that into the dynamic
you create that pause or that gap
you create that emptiness that space
and in doing so you
create this
re-harmonization of
the possibility space where it can be
more
vibrated frequency wise towards love
light unity
and away from the
separate people arguing because they
don't know themselves as god having a
conversation with
itself
yeah it's a very good way to put it
and that's why i also say all the time
you know
to anybody that
you know because when these challenges
arise these arguments this friction
arises and experience automatically the
mind is
resisting it it wishes it was otherwise
it and oftentimes we have these ideas
that as i'm becoming more aware
as i'm becoming more spiritual that you
know
it's just i'll just flow and no more
problems whereas
these these situations and these um
conversations and these unique
challenges
arise and these are our greatest
opportunities
rather than to be resented and resisted
see in that moment of argument with your
partner perhaps
see what what what belief what idea
what mental position you are so
subscribed to
what what are you defending what are you
contracting
into what are you trying to prove
you know and this is this is the
spiritual practice
it's perhaps one of the the greatest
spiritual practices
is that life naturally brings us to you
you don't even need to
go do this it's just an automatic
arising
and it happens just even if you renounce
everything and you're sitting
and you're still go you know life is
still gonna happen and so
it will even find avenues in that regard
and so when those things arise rather
than
now going further deeply into that
judgment
aspect the psychological mind
just churning more and more you you have
to in that moment acknowledge
you know what it what can i let go of
what am i what is
coming to the surface right now and
that's that subtle
subtle vacation we were talking about is
that previously let's say
you weren't even able to acknowledge you
know these sorts of identifications and
and things that you were bought into in
that moment but now you're
it's that that deeper eye
of awareness that is that you're able to
reflect that light upon
what you are currently buying into that
can be let go of that you can release
and almost every single time you do so
you you notice yourself as you just said
it refreshes that infinite possibility
and you notice how things take a more
harmonious turn
although that is not necessarily the
goal of this
that generally tends to happen so let's
say in that argument with your partner
if you acknowledge that you know because
the mind is very good at making you
believe that oh it's just the other
person that's incorrect
and you know my position is very very
true and it makes sense
and although it's very logical and
easily believed in
when you acknowledge that it all it also
is just a limited point of view
and you're seeing this point of view
from the view
in which points of view arrive views our
eyes
then becomes that willingness to to ease
on that point of view to no longer want
to prove its
correctness or defend it and that when
that when you lay down the arms when you
let go of that
defending and you just ease off now once
again that
that flow is sort of reignited
and it's so in in that way it's a
beautiful
uh sort of process even we
created this
incredible reality
as one intelligence at play with itself
where we can call it like we wrote below
catalysts as
is said in the law of one that
these are our greatest
tool for awakening yes
so when we gain this subtlification like
we've been talking about
we no longer come in
as a victim
it's a shift from being a contracted
victim to being the very
creator of the scenario for
myself to experience the
catalyst to awaken
to what it's trying to teach me
and then in doing so i recognize that
this entire reality is designed to guide
us
all home exactly
yeah and that's the the step three right
the
integration aspect as we discussed
earlier obviously conversations like
this
and then silence allowing yourself to
actually marinate in
in no concepts and then this is the
integration process which you don't do
it happens and you must just be willing
in that in that regard be willing to
step up
and and you know so uh sometimes people
say then how to bring this willingness
forth
and i i've come to see that it is a
direct
byproduct of your wanting the truth
rather than wanting to be right or or
to to have this experience to be
following or pursuing your mental
objective
you have to want to be to be free of of
that
and so this willingness this ability to
step up
and let go arises in likewise proportion
and this always reminds me of uh a quote
by nisargadatta maharaj he always says
you want reality but you're afraid of it
you cling to that which is not real so
so in that that step three it really
tests us
you know in silence we have these great
discoveries and
and um and the understanding begins to
develop but then
your experience will really demand that
you
live the implications of what you're
discovering
so you may have to take a big risk in
perhaps a work project or
act in a totally different manner in
in your relationship whatever this
moment is calling for
you may have to
pursue something you may be calling to
be pursuing something
in which everything is on the line and
you have no idea how it's going to work
out
right that uncertainty element is going
to be so reignited in life
and in that moment like will you embrace
uncertainty or will you
succumb to it will you run away from it
which is funny though because
the uncertainty aspect of experience is
what we crave most
you know the excitement the
unpredictability
is what we love most we hate when life
becomes structured
when when and we even have an expression
for it is that like the life is getting
sucked out of it
right what is getting sucked out of it
it is the unpredictable factor
so once we embrace uncertainty
now it no longer becomes a reason to
fear
not knowing is no longer a reason to
fear it's actually
perhaps your greatest excitement because
now truly you don't know what's gonna
happen
and and you you give that control over
realizing that you
are not the the sole cause for how
things work out in your life you give
that control over to life and i've
experienced
that as one of the most beautiful things
because
truly then you're removing the
structures
you're removing all these because with
the structures go
the belief systems and all this mental
nonsense on behalf of which we suffer on
behalf of which many of
our limiting ideas are are resting
you know so truly uh we
we love the the first aspect of it the
discussion and philosophy
we kind of like the silence aspect of it
because it's relaxing but
nobody talks about the third which is
the difficult part
yet it is perhaps the the most
fulfilling
in that regard which is where the the
true conviction really arises
when you put everything on the line when
you act according to understanding and
then you see obviously the mind can
never see from this point of view
point in time how this is unfolding and
if i'm going to be okay but then you
continue to see
you know there's something that's just
taking care of it all without you
wanting without you clinging without you
resisting
it's still just flowing experience is
still just flowing
and so that that's the harmonious aspect
um
that start that quality the harmonious
quality of life that begins to
arise
yeah so many great
bits there
the surrender to faith trust
perfection that we already are
and the integration
portion which is when your
silence really meets the test
when the catalyst appears
are you so
equanimous and so
unable to be triggered
that you just
hold the space for the re-harmonization
of the distortion that approach the
field
and so you begin
acting as god perpetually
rebalancing itself towards
harmony away from distortion and ego
and conditioning of separation
and as you said in this quote as well
that you want reality but you're afraid
of it you cling to the unreal
and that can very beautifully
also be expressed through
this visual which is
the very conditioning that we spent
years developing of being a separate
finite biological entity
among a bunch of other separate finite
biological entities
that have no relation whatsoever to each
other
in a finite physical reality
that entire structure
is the unreal
it is most unreal the separation
the affinity the
conditioning and when you do nothing
and you recognize that emptiness in
silence
like we've been talking about
people struggle
with that because what you see there
in that castle is their
attachment to the years
of their
lattice work developing yeah
that's the hardest thing to let go of
it's this
arrogant i already know everything
non-humble latticework
that's where this sort of i need to
force my point of view because i already
know
as a separate entity among a bunch of
other separate entities
i know and i'm going to force my
perspective in
given my lattice work of years of study
of the specific thing that i already
know
and the silence
like we saw it just collapses
that lattice work to the divine
surrender
faith truth perfection of
recognizing re-identifying oneself
as the very source of reality itself
this very earnestness to know and be the
truth
of freedom to be the freedom
that you already are and to surrender to
the very
one intelligence at play with itself
that you already are
that seems to be the most
common
late stage part of awakening is
just the divine faithful
surrender to the one intelligence
that we already are at play with itself
and just knowing that
the proper silence will arise as it does
the proper integration will arise as it
does
there will be a proper subification
as it comes there will be the
replenishing
as it comes and it's just
ineffably indescribably perfect
already and that's sort of what we come
to
as this realization which is sort of
what i
mentioned at the beginning which is that
and kind of hold both of these
simultaneously which is
it's already always
perfect and free and yet at the same
time
there seems to be this contracted
energy of not knowing what silence is
because we're so attached to what's
appearing on the screen to the noises
and so then there's the process of
this personal mast request of ah
how do i become
more aware of the screen itself how do i
become more aware
of the silence and what does that enable
how does that enable me to access the
truth and the freedom
and the perfection and the divinity the
kingdom of god that's
already there
the one word you use earnestness i love
that word
and such an essay that's a word yeah
and yeah earnestness is that
it is that which brings
that willingness to let go you know of
your investment
and your beliefs your investment and
what you know to
what is familiar we can say it is what
enables you to take that leap of faith
and trust not only trust the teaching
the words but also trust life
to take care of life and it's
and you know i love the the simplicity
also of
ramana maharishi's teaching because you
know how we broke it down into three
aspects like the the concept silence and
integration
his was just silence and
integration in a way because he used to
say that
either inquire or surrender you know or
and it's really both either either one
you choose you're doing both
you know and and that that really is and
and sometimes we
resist the fact that it can be that
simple
the mind wants to dwell in uh concepts
it wants to
continue to just keep
it finds especially in the very uh
beginning when you're
encountering this teaching
being aware that you are aware
just doesn't seem enough until you start
to
really um acknowledge
its depth it's it's freedom
yes and then you you and automatically
the mind recognizes this that okay then
it can be this simple i i can surrender
and that's we can that's like the
purification of the mind
the mind is going from being very very
gross
uh lost in its concepts to becoming more
subtler and subtler itself
and we we noticed this as the mind
becoming quieter
and also just being more willing you
know in that way
and it just comes back to silence you
know that that is
the place that is the place to start and
end
it's fascinating watching the 2020s
roar into the
simultaneous
even more
noise
even more people on the internet
even more people
seeing the
attention economy as a big land grab
and so
becoming attached to
posting to garner
attention in the land grab out of
in many ways unworthiness
i will get validation from people
with my follower counts and my likes
and
i by only knowing myself as a
separate finite entity
must
create a trace
which is impossible because this is all
traceless
i must create a trace
through a wikipedia page
and that is going on in the 2020s
at the same time
the silence and the internal
is happening and it's fascinating
watching it unfold
where there's this very clear
movement and galvanizing of attention
on all the answers are within shut the
[ __ ] up
at the same time that there is this
explosion of tick-tock
and it's almost like both are attractors
they're like vortexes right the
inward is its own attractor and vortex
of wow
i love being the honey
itself
muji talks about our
preference to taste the honey rather
than be it
right and then there's this other
attractor
which is the in many ways it's like maya
the illusion the intoxication and that
this one is also like a vortex because
when you get onto the platform
even if it's youtube or instagram or
facebook or twitter
let alone tick tock which is the most
attention locking of them all
it's a vortex and
what's happening is you're
treating your attention carelessly
most simply put you get to do whatever
you want because you're always already
free
that's the beauty of it yet at the same
time
if you truly care about
what spirituality is or what spiritual
understanding is
or what silence can bring to your life
to undergo the process that sunny and i
have been
talking about throughout the basic how
which
you led us through a very simple
practice of how to become aware
of the screen
just the very essence of
silence itself
creating this pause creating this gap
even eckhart tolle has went so far as to
say that
you are more conscious
the more of a gap and a pause
that you have so you're less conscious
you're
more robotic you're more algorithmic
you're more scripted
when you simply react
to a stimulus rather than knowing how to
just
observe witness
and people to see what is it teaching
me what is it teaching the others in
this scenario
the other selves the this is this
it's the perceptual
bentino masaro has also said that
everything that appears in consciousness
is
based on identity
if you're identifying as dao
versus if you're identifying as a
separate person
because if you're identifying as a
separate person you have and you have no
pause
you have no gap what's going to appear
in your consciousness
is suffering getting triggered anger
emotions frustration
versus if you're residing in the dao
as allowed to said the master resides
endow if you're residing in it
what appears in consciousness is this
sort of perpetual
honey the perpetual suttlification
purification freedom truth
surrender divinity
and it's up to you you're free to choose
if you want to reunite
with that
i like the honey i like the honey
i think if we're blessed enough that the
teaching has come
into our experience then as you said
earlier then we must
be we must care more
where the attention is going then you
actually because otherwise it's just
blindedness without knowing you are
blinded now as
when this teaching arises in your
experience
now almost comes with a greater sense of
responsibility from the relative choice
making that you have
now you must tend to
where your attention is going
what keeps our attention hooked
is the incessant thinkingness which
revolves just around craving and
resisting
it's so true if you just do a little
inventory of your thinking for one day
you see how it literally just revolves
it's just all interpretations and
judgments
on on things you want and things you
don't want
and as you said earlier in this thinking
it's reinforcing the identity of being a
certain thing
certain somebody who can want or not
want
so it keeps that blindedness that
illusion
very very alive and real
and so it goes back to the earlier point
that we made one of the the greatest
freedoms you can give to yourself
is to even look at even your own
likes and dislikes preferences and
resistances
desires and fears with a certain lack of
interest
with a certain detachment it it because
there lies our bondage
you know how much we believe our own
likes and dislikes preferences and
resistances for how much how this
experience should unfold
for what the world should be for what i
want to become for what i should be
as soon as we relax those
or relax the because they may still
arise let them arise
watch them arise become aware that wow
you know become aware of it's an amazing
spiritual practice become aware of your
own
selfish interests yes you know always
this craving to manipulate experience
other people
see the this uh inch self-interest
to to gain to to
want praise to want to avoid
pain to avoid anything that may be
unpleasant
watch all these things arise within you
do nothing of them
simply become aware that they are
arising and when you become aware that
they are rising then you can
you have the capacity to turn away to no
longer
go with it because previously it was
arising and it was just
finding expression without any sort of
uh monitoring
but now we're blessed that okay this
teaching has arisen in experience it is
guiding you towards this
trust the words and that because having
faith in the words is perhaps the first
step without which you won't even
practice and then you see that in your
own experience yes
you become way more aware all these
things that were previously just arising
in the background
or weren't even knowingly arising they
were just operating as you
as what i am now they're arising and
there's an awareness of them you're able
to watch them you're not resisting them
you're not fighting them
you're not trying to turn them into
something more positive it's just you're
watching them arise
and in that lies the freedom to turn
away
and therefore now all these things
become weaker and their ability to
[Music]
reinforce that identity as a certain
somebody with a story
or being here as something becomes
weaker
therefore you become more and more
established
in your non-physical identity as that
which is aware
and so you brought it back artoli
earlier and i there was one
teaching of his which uh always
resonated with me
he said you know as asburg going through
this subtlification as this purification
process
be comfortable not knowing what you are
when you are observing be comfortable
not
attributing
a thought or a feeling or a name or a
shape or a form
to that which is observing observe as
a nothing and be comfortable not being
a something don't
itch at any concept don't just
crave you know some sort of physical
entity physical identity from which you
must operate
see that all that you know all that all
that we
what we consider the world what we even
believe ourselves to be
is an object within the seeing
and when everything you know as life
life as we know it all of it comes in
the seeing
that is when this deeper curiosity goes
up even more it's like
then what is it that would that what
that which is aware
as what am i aware
any object any concept any idea that i
can come up with
is seen
it itself is a thought
perhaps the subtlest of thoughts but as
what am i
aware of it if this is so subtle so
invisible
it may not even be a thought it may be
like you know some sort of underlying
like
uh concept or belief but still i am
aware of it
as what i must i be aware of it
that which is subtler than even this
subtle thought appearing
and so that's the freedom that starts
to um become very very real the moment
you
create a distance between you and your
likes and dislikes your preferences and
resistances
it allows you to create a distance from
everything
the distance is a very necessary step
obviously the integration is then
once again going within it and you know
going through that but
the the distance is a very very good
first step
you create a distance between that which
is aware and what it is aware of
and not attributing it to an object not
attributing it to something
acknowledging that anything knowable
cannot be what i
am in essence
and and that is the the sense of
responsibility that i
talk about that arises when when the
teaching
comes into our experience now be
interested in this because
why because you know what else is more
interesting
you know people are always afraid of
like this may go out of my life this may
go out of my life
first of all anything that just goes out
of your life wasn't worth
protecting anyway and then second
see what you are waking up to
it is much more
of of you can say for a value of
interest
if we're talking about you know there's
another quote that i love from him he
says
nothing of value can happen to a mind
that knows exactly what it wants
for nothing the mind can want is of much
value
the mind operates in the realm of the
noble
it itself is unknowable
so that is the interest
which you are diverting now instead of
being so interested in that which is
known be interested in
that which is knowing yes
and that is the the ripeness that is the
subtlification the purification
purification of what mind not you
mind it enhances the mind's ability to
reflect that which is
without distortion without making it
appear to be something else
yes you know because we're always saying
all sorts of things about
i am this i am that our eye is dancing
all the time
wearing different shapes different masks
different costumes
and we say like it's our truth you know
so that's the beautiful part about
self-inquiry it
takes the simplest statements you take
to be true
that you don't even consciously think
out loud but these are your assumptions
and it brings all of them
into question yeah and one once you are
interested in this questioning
already that is freedom ensuing
questioning your assumptions yields
freedom
the very process of self-inquiry itself
will give rise to
all of these things that were taken as
assumptions
which then creates
the gnostic individual
the mystic the yogi the one that has
united
with god because they have
turned inward
and through the turn inward the
very defocusing
on objects
and the uniting with
that which observes witnesses
sees is conscious of is aware of
all that is the space
that is the emptiness that is
abided as with silence
and with just the earnestness to see
what is what is on the other shore
of the obsessive compulsive focusing on
objects
what is on the other shore what is on
the shore of becoming aware
of that witch sees
and what is on the other shore is the
well of honey
that is under the rock as aurobindo and
the mother said and
at the end of the day there are no
shores
and and at the end of the day there are
also shores
and that's the game is simultaneity so
do you um
all we're talking about here with
spiritual understanding
is yielding more freedom do you feel
like you're free
is your obsession with objects and
thoughts and
perceptions and sensations and beliefs
in your point of view
and being a separate finite entity
trying to extract
peace and happiness from maya yielding
you great freedom
because if the answer to that is no then
all you have to do is turn inward
all you have to do is relax become aware
of what is
that which knows your experience
and might it be the same thing that
knows the experience of sonny
might it be the same that knows the
experience of atlas
this be a manifestation of eternity
of infinity an appearance
a cameo a dream
and might you be the very source
of all possibility
it boils down to freedom baby boils down
to freedom
i think one of the best discoveries also
to be made
in experience is that no experience can
bring you that freedom
because no matter how spiritual you
become no matter how
deep you go into non-dual philosophy
some part of you still starts keeps
craving
experiences you know you you
may be on the surface level you're like
yes i no longer believe that
the next job or the next vacation can
bring me that happiness but something
continues to pursue that sort of energy
remains
it has certain momentum and so
going through the experiences that you
have been craving for very long
those are your moments of reflection be
aware in those moments
see how even in those moments the mind
is restless
and those moments pass that experience
also passes and it leaves you in the
same craving
and this you only have to go through
so many times before you you wake up to
this some some may never do
but if you're truly bringing your if
you're truly attentive to experience
you very very quickly will see this you
know
and this will then facilitate that going
inward
because you will see that the answer
does not lie within experience
it is never bringing you that sense of
fulfillment
that sense of wholeness that sense that
happiness
that peacefulness that you seek through
objects
yes no object is capable of bringing you
this yep
yep i swear
on
sitting and doing nothing
yields more peace
and happiness than
the most extravagant
luxurious experience
i swear on it and it's only deepening
it flipped the early parts of my life
were the opposite where you could say
maya was higher and awareness was lower
and now my life has flipped where
awareness
the very emptiness brings the peace and
happiness
and the maya the experiences
are like yeah
you can go to mexico or
yeah you like yeah you can
skydive or jet ski or
have a one night stand or
do dmt like the experience
list is endless but
know that none of those
bring what you seek
come all the way in first
and then
experience what you please because if
you want to
at that point say let's go to thailand
then do that from the place of knowing
that you're bringing
peace and happiness to thailand
not that you're going to thailand to
extract peace and happiness yeah yeah
and sometimes hearing it is not enough i
know two three
four years ago if i heard it wouldn't
have been enough for me so you just have
to go through that
and and that's perhaps also a very
appropriate empowerment phase where you
are really bought into
no it i need this i want this
and going through that you know so i i
always encourage people to go through
that if you really believe in that
go through that and experience it for
yourself but just do so
with a certain level of attentiveness
don't be blinded by experience
be attentive see if experiencing exactly
what you had wanted to experience
if it is bringing you that level of
satisfaction that level of fulfillment
not momentarily but even when it passes
that's also something to acknowledge
that it passes yeah
and see if that brings rest you know
if that brings that sense of fulfillment
and once you
really start to acknowledge this then
you will know then you'll have that
different relationship with
experience where you will no longer give
it that false reality that belief
and you will no longer all these
cravings and resistances that continue
to arise
will have less belief then you won't
just
[Music]
let anything find expression many things
that are arising in mind will just be
discarded and they will vanish
their vanishing will not make you any
lesser
their vanishing will not make your
experience your life fall apart
you know and so
once that turning inward
starts to occur once you fully
acknowledge that yes experience cannot
bring me
what i want then as you said
as you go inward as you reconnect with
what you are
or become what you or be as you are
then the expression may find its own
then it may dance as as it is programmed
to do
you know because often times a fear
arises of
fear of loss on the spiritual path
whereas
the only thing you're losing is delusion
if you are if you're if the programming
is
you're going to be very active and
involved and this and that and you're
going to be all in
you know in action with all these people
that will
continue to find expression but if the
programming is
being quiet and retracting or or
leaving oh you know just um living that
very simple life then that will be it
ultimately it will be your enjoyment
also
so not fearing any loss see that
anything worth
anything that you can lose is not worth
clinging on to once you really
acknowledge this then just be that open
be open to anything that comes
let it come anything that goes let it go
once you become this empty sort of
vessel
allowing the flow of experience then
not only does this harmony ensue
but also experiences capacity to
blind you to further pull you into
identification it ceases
yes so it's a beautiful
aspect of this whole journey
i love this point that the bliss from
the experience
comes and goes and that's a direct
experiential realization
as long as you become subtle enough to
notice it
why right after the one night stand
dmt experience travel to thailand etc
did
i come back feeling sad
right when it was done yeah why was
there a void
that needed to be filled again versus
what is being discussed as this pure
aware
being and how could that
possibly be itself
an inexhaustible well of bliss and peace
how could that be what is called
sachitanda
how is that possible let me investigate
and upon that earnest investigation
the realization is yielded but
it will not yield
to those that do not seek
to reunite with it so
you are again already always free
perfect unlimited
eternal
yet it remains for you to recognize it
that's a beautiful sufi metaphysic that
basically sums up the
non-dual with the duel in one
only the ignorance seek what is already
there
yet it remains for you to recognize it
i often have i have this rule
anytime um you begin to
go into a lot of concepts
anytime even let's say we're like we're
in a discussion today and
we've gone off into a lot of talking and
concepts
and just coming back to that simplicity
once again
acknowledging that i
am aware all the words that
came in have gone and even the words
that are arising
continue to just vanish
and become very dreamlike
literally even the beginning of this
talk
you have to you it has a very similar
quality to the dream that you had last
night
you know it is equally unreal and soon
the contents of this moment
also will become very very unreal
just a memory
but go to the core
of experience
i am aware is very
very it's shining forth
it's very self-evident
and and that's the curiosity to to
cultivate
as what am i aware no longer just
assuming
right because we love to put it an image
to it like i this body
this thing is aware
but no longer just assuming
be aware
and investigate as what am i aware
because anything that you attribute that
this is what is aware
you will quickly see in in this inquiry
that
it is a thing which is which you are
aware of
it is seen it is observed
and so you must go through this this
curiosity will really help you
see clearly that anything that you can
cultivate
or that you can create as this is what
is aware
anything that the mind can come up with
is simply
something you're already aware of
so as what am i aware of that
don't battle against the thoughts that
are arising it let the mind do what it
does
the mind thinks the thoughts are not the
problem
but you must simply establish your true
position
as what are you aware of the
thinkingness
and instead of being so interested in
the
content of the thinking be
interested genuinely and that that's
such an important word
genuinely not for some gain not for some
blissful experience
but the only thing that you can seem to
care about
is as what am i aware what is the knower
you know what knows and it will always
bring you back to that utter simplicity
it will always bring bring
the mind into the heart of awareness
hello
it's a gorgeous rap thank you
that's wonderful talking to you it's
perfect i'm glad we did this
thanks for leading us on those two
meditations those two
inquiries very profound
very good thank you
great dialectic
super looking forward to continued
creating together sonny you're powerful
you're so powerful my brother
love you lord happy to connect with you
it's so powerful
love it
grateful to our audience for catching
the pattern and
yes very excited for that person to see
this
hopefully they're watching already there
were a couple
and even in the comments from
today we had uh
we had gratitude for this live stream
thankful for each and every one of the
universe divide creator unconditionally
love you all
serving mindful awareness
sunny yeah
the inward and outward honey vortices
expanding parabolically at once
perhaps it can't happen any other way so
interesting
yep as what am i aware repeat
[Music]
awesome all right everyone thank you so
much for tuning in
infinite love to you thank you check out
the links in the bio below
to sonny's youtube channel and also his
website he has so much great
free content there for you to check out
and also if the video brought you value
give it a like helps the algorithm
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
yet leave us a comment below
with your thoughts we'll come back we'll
jump in
and hit the tennis ball
over to you supper us infinite love yo
[Laughter]
and share the conversation with people
that you feel like this would resonate
with
and that is all
thank you everyone
and
we will
see you soon thank you everybody thank
you atlas
thanks sonny thanks